well this is a document uh printed off
from the government's website runs to 12
pages
and it is basically telling us who
can apply to be exempt from the
self-isolation
the pandemic and as you might expect
it's people in critical services ranging
from
transport to emergency services in the
document in the guidance it says this
policy only applies if you or your
employer
has received a letter from a government
department on which your name is listed
and it begins by saying that
self-isolation remains
an essential tool so it's important to
stress these are exemptions
who it applies to well as a list here
and it says that arrangements have
already in place for frontline
health and care staff but we know about
that that was announced a few days ago
but here's the crucial list um
energy is one area obviously the power
stations keeping the lights switched on
throughout the uk and civil
nuclear power so presumably nuclear
power stations so
energy crucial uh fuel uh gas
um um electricity generation nuclear
power
then digital infrastructure that's
keeping broadband switched on
making sure that everyone's got wi-fi
and so on businesses have got it
and next comes food production and
supply
well we're expecting to hear more about
some measures
by the government to keep to solve the
crisis or
at least help try and deal with the
crisis of empty shells in the
supermarkets
but food production and supply is one of
the areas on this list
um so that uh could there be everything
from uh
food processing plants uh uh the meat
industries being
very critical today of the problems
about the problems they're facing
uh abattoir slaughterhouses meat
production all sorts of food production
waste so that's sewage most important in
the hot weather no doubt
uh water keeping making sure the uh
there's plenty of water in our taps the
reservoirs are
given despite the dry weather are able
to supply enough water
veterinary medicines um obviously for
agriculture as well as
for uh domestic pets no doubt essential
chemicals
then comes essential transport well
obviously that's
everything from air traffic controllers
railway signalers the government's
talking about but also uh people are
working on the buses the trains
and the tube in london
next comes medicines supply of medicines
medical devices obviously all sorts of
medical equipment
clinical consumer supply consumable
supplies
that's presumably pills in the chemist
and the supermarket
then comes emergency services well this
obviously is predictable uh police fire
services and so on
um and then the border control uh
obviously a very contentious area at the
moment with all the
uh debate about border controls uh
border controls on the list
then essential defense outputs well that
must be barracks and all sorts of
protection of
um all sorts of security and protection
um ministry of defense establishments
raf
navy and so on essential defense outputs
it says here and then local government
well that's obviously relates to
keeping the bins uh emptied there have
been suggestions that
some councils are short of refuse
collectors and the bins are under threat
so a great long list there um obvious
predictable uh the areas that we know
have been suffering
we are expecting to hear more about
moves to
keep supplies of food and other goods to
supermarkets
a little later yes i mean it comes to
something john doesn't it
when you need an exemption to keep the
lights on in the country
but can i just clarify is that exempt if
you're double jabbed or just exempt
yes that's right i will i will read you
what it says it says
um yeah that this policy applies to
named workers in specifically approved
workplaces
who are fully vaccinated defined as
someone who is 14 days
post final dose and who have been
identified as close
contacts it says that permission to
attend work is contingent on following
certain controls
agreed by department of health this is
not a blanket exemption
for all workers in a sector it says but
yes it is uh
fully uh fully vaccinated and somebody
who's had it
at least 14 days ago and just quickly
um any sign of confidence from
government
about whether this would be enough well
they obviously hope it will and uh
on the sky news earlier today
quasi-cuateng was uh
was talking about fingers crossed that
was a phrase he used
an interview with k burley when he was
talking about uh
uh the whole tackling the whole pandemic
problem
um the government as you know uh
is gonna get rid of this uh this uh
these ping
process on the 16th of uh august
fingers crossed said mr quarten today in
the house of commons
jeremy hunt who chairs the health select
committee and is a former health
secretary
called on nadim zahawi who was making a
common statement
to uh not wait till the 16th of august
do it now he said
well the answer from mr zahawi as it has
been from the new
uh health secretary sajid javid is
no we want to wait until the 16th of
august to
get rid of the isolation rules as they
currently stand
because more people will have been
vaccinated by them
that has been the government's argument
but there is growing pressure
from mps like jeremy hans and of course
business leaders who are thoroughly
frustrated and fed up
with the vast numbers of people being
forced to self-isolate there is pressure
to bring that august 16th date
forward much sooner